I'm George I'm ways we've been married
now almost nine years couple years after
married we started a family and as we've
been married about a year and a half and
had our first daughter and year and a
half after that had our second daughter
two years later had our third daughter
and then last year we welcomed a little
boy growing up my dad was a was a farmer
and so growing up through that learned a
lot about a lot about money but it used
as typical with most most farmers a lot
of times they use a lot of debt and so
it's kind of how I was taught to hang up
in this that's kind of where I went when
I was growing up I was the third kid in
mine and parents didn't talk a lot about
money but it wasn't like a hush-hush
topic either and so um I kind of had
avoided credit cards all the way through
college although I did end up having
some student loan and stuff like that
shortly after we were married we found a
local church that was putting on FPU
took a lot of the the information we
didn't totally buy it all that point
things kind of turned upside down for us
when our third daughter became sick
turns out she was diagnosed with a
malignant tumor and our world just
turned upside down she was just 12
months old at the time we had a almost
two year old and a three year old at the
time and everything stopped
to find out your child has cancer is
just startling I mean it's it's
indescribable
we ended up just kind of holding on you
know it we just were in survival mode no
more you know grocery planning or
anything it was just you had to feed the
family just grabbed food put it on the
table and in survival mode for for quite
some time
we were in the local Children's Hospital
in the oncology unit I was sitting there
and I just I mean I was obviously
terrified for her but also I'm like how
much is this going to cost us
she ended up having six rounds of
chemotherapy over the next six months or
so she'd have one week of chemo in the
hospital and then we have two weeks home
we had a couple extra visits back to the
hospital in those two weeks sometimes
with complications overall that's that's
what we did we were just holding on
through that time it was amazing how
much generosity we were blessed with
people we didn't know we're friends of
friends we would be get a gift card in
the mail or for gas or groceries or
whatever it was just incredibly
overwhelming to be given that much
support and help by some stranger's I
mean friends former co-workers that we
hadn't worked with or seen in years just
amazing how fortunate we felt that
people entrusted us here we think you
need this and it was such a blessing to
us I felt responsible for making sure
that we got in a position where we could
do the same thing that's really one of
the turning point happened when we
really kind of said no we need to need
to get debt free and get debt free as
soon as we can
we started not eating out as much not
doing you know really finding those
those spots in the budget where we could
find that extra money to start throwing
at canceled Netflix she started you know
selling everything in the house
switching the cash you know kept me
accountable the envelope sympathy you
know we're going to have what's in the
cabinet and often the end of the month
we have some interesting meals if you
can call them meals I'm not sure
sometimes what's really important in
life I think that's what's really
changed our perspective over the last
couple years of this process of between
the illness and then also just getting
to be debt-free you know what what's
important to us is it is it is it
curtains and nice cars or is it health
and and helping others and having a
testimony to share and encourage others
now that we are debt free and kind of
feel like we've got our own household
taken care of we hope to just be able to
give I mean it's kind of a constant
reminder we have to remind ourselves
that it's not our money anyway it's
God's money and and that we need to seek
His guidance in what we need to do with
what we've been blessed with